[Musique]
ghana le break bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle think ur view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
merci de m'avoir avec vous je m'appelle
glen au breite je suis philosophe
environnementale australien j'ai créé le
concept de cela ce talent j
qui apparaît dans mon livre qui vient
d'être publié en français en france aux
éditions les liens qui libèrent et je
travaille comme philosophe
environnementales tout au long de ma
carrière
mon dernier poste était
professeur de durabilité à l'université
de murdoch appel
est ce que vous connaissez la devise de
soeur murdoch
c'est pas le murdoch de la presse
murdoch ses soeurs walter murdoch un
essayiste
et c'était un écrivain célèbre est un
essayiste australiens mais je ne connais
pas son
il avait
un proverbe sur l'éducation
une une bonne éducation doit vous
apprendre à penser par vous même et ne
pas avaler la mode que le monde moderne
essaye de vous faire avaler je résume sa
trivialement vous connaissiez ça non je
savais que c'était un homme très
intelligent qu'il avait de l'esprit mais
je n'ai connu que par le nom de
diversité de murdoch et je dois dire aux
gens non il s'agit pas droit pertes nord
doc ses soeurs walter murdoch donc je
suis très heureux d'être associé à cette
université et as il y avait combien de
pays combien d'élèves sur votre
université
la dernière fois que j'y étais c'était
d'environ 20000 mais j'ai pris ma
retraite en 2014 et je ne sais pas quels
sont les chiffres actuels
et je ne connais pas le destin de
murdoch university en 2020 et en 2020 il
y avait si les chiffres sont bons + 17
mille étudiants 1700 enseignants et 90
nationalités représentées quand vous
enseigner la balle la perception des
émotions concernant le collapse
écologique le changement du biotope
quelle a été la réaction de vos élèves
c'était intéressant
lorsque j'ai présenté la première fois
ses idées cette nouvelle partie de
l'enseignement j'ai tenté de les faire
rentrer dans sa
un programme déjà classique de sujets
classiques sur l'environnement donc je
donnais souvent une conférence séparés
comme faisant partie de mes activités de
philosophes et c'est ainsi que
je parlais pas seulement mes étudiants
mais toute l'université j'ai entendu des
idées comme la soul la stalle j la
symbiose scène le symbio scène et
d'autres idées qui j'ai développé pour
les
tester pour la première fois face à un
public pour voir comment ils réagissent
et c'est toujours difficile d'introduire
de nouvelles cités dans un monde qui est
déjà très occupé et plaint de ce que les
gens pensent conventionnellement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous nous
définir ce que c'est l'amoureux d'y
finir ce que c'est la seule à ce stade j
est ce que c'est un état dépressif est
ce que c'est une nouvelle mémétique
culturel est ce que c'est un
c'est nouveau je le décrirais comme
d'une expérience vécue une expérience
émotionnelle
qui relie
l'état du territoire de la région
du lieu on en a bit à un certain état
d'esprit que je décrirais comme
de la désolation
détresse parce que on a plus de plaisir
ou de confort
d'un endroit qui était cherrier aimé par
ses résidents donc c'est défini comme
une définition
une certaine un mal du pays lorsque vous
êtes dans votre propre pays
les plus techniquement c'est
l'expérience vécue
d'un changement négatif dans votre
environnement propre
infliger
cette détresse que vous ressentez parce
qu'il ya cette différence entre vous et
votre domicile votre maison par
contraste avec ce concept de nostalgie
qui avaient été définis par ofer en 16
188 c'est le mal du pays quand on est
loin de chez vous et que vous souhaiter
retourner chez vous vous êtes par
exemple loin dans un environnement
étranger et votre mal du pays est
tellement puissant que ça peut affecter
votre santé mentale et physique
le résultat le la solution pour guérir
le mal du pays c'est de vous rapatrier
vers la patrie
tels que c'était des cris à cette époque
la seule stahl fils et la différence et
le pose c'est l'opposé vous êtes chez
vous c'est votre environnement qui vous
quittent et vous en êtes triste donc la
solution à la seule ostalgie
c'est de réparer restaurer
l'environnement qui était le vôtre pour
vous faire revenir vers un état
précédent de plénitude et d'appartenance
si si on n'arrive pas
si on n'arrive pas à restaurer le
biotope environnemental autour de chez
soi qu'est ce qui se passe
psychologiquement et qu'est ce que ça
peut générer chez les gens est ce que ça
génère de l'agressivité est-ce que ça
génère de des comportements lymphatique
démissionnaire est ce que ça génère
d'autres attitudes 1
ça peut générer une variété de réaction
l'idée que l'on a besoin de restaurer
quelque chose pour que ce soit la
réplique de ce que c'était le passé ne
fait pas partie de la définition de la
ce la salle j on peut réparer restaurer
dans une certaine mesure mais pour créer
un nouvel environnement qui donne
un certain degré de plénitude d'identité
et de but dans la vie donc il n'y a pas
de connexion obligatoire avec le passé
dans ce concept de cela ce talent j donc
ce n'est pas de la nostalgie c'est par
définition
un état
qui peut être amélioré à l'avenir mais
pas une réplique exacte du passé
toutefois si votre environnement et
ruiné par
des mines d'excavation des guerres de
choses de ce genre
ça peut être véritablement changement
important dans votre environnement parce
que ce sera difficile de s'en occuper
sans éliminer les causes dans le cas de
la solde d'alger dans ma définition
j'avais à l'esprit la cause qu'ils
étaient les mines à ciel ouvert dans la
région de la vallée du rhône seul en
australie ces mines de charbon qui
s'étendent sur des centaines de
kilomètres carrés est la solution à
cette nostalgie c'était de lutter contre
les mines de charbon donc voilà la
réaction cette réaction peut être tout
qui va de
plantons des arbres
faisons en sorte que l'endroit
reverdissent à il faut lutter contre les
multinationales et le gouvernement
australien si on veut allégez las olas
talent j et revenir un environnement qui
nous donne vérité mans du confort
c'est pas trop tarder un d'entreprendre
ce type d'attitude de restaurer de
planter des arts d'essayer de vivre en
communauté avec un capitalisme qui est
galopant sans
borne de ris without any sans contrôle
sans s'en sont toutes ces choses là est
ce que la société qui consomme de façon
exponentielle n'est pas devenu tellement
importante que je dirais été pensés
utopiste ou de prise de conscience de la
sonas talent j
c'est pas un peu trop tard
c'était utopique ça serait pas trop tard
parce que le tapis est un état
inatteignable même s'il est désirable
je dirais que là cela stahl j
c'est une réaction
réaliste
une situations dans lesquelles les
humains se sont placés et en tant que
tels ils peuvent s'en sortir
ça devient une question de volonté
la raison pour laquelle
j'essaie de position pour dire que ce
n'est pas trop tard c'est que en tant
que vieilli j'ai vécu les années 60 et
70 une époque où les gens pensaient que
un changement radical pouvait prendre
place
et c'était le moment où le mur de berlin
s'est écroulé alors que les gens
disaient non non ça se produirait jamais
ça jamais
enlever ce mur de berlin et le lendemain
il y avait des images de jeunes garçons
de jeunes filles avec des marteaux qui
le réduisent et en petits bouts
on ne peut pas me dire que le changement
ne pas se produire et peut pas se rendre
rapidement gelé vu se produire nous
luttions dans les années 60 70 contre la
nidation nucléaire j'ai manifesté contre
les français qui faisait exploser des
bombes atomiques à muret roi donc moi
j'ai manifesté contre les américains
parce qu'ils avaient commencé la guerre
du vietnam et l'australie a pris part
donc
je je peux voir moins que cette
expérience vécue du changement social et
du potentiel du changement social est
quelque chose qui reste avec nous et je
le vois dans ces génération la
génération z
superbe génération
qui n'ont pas leurs parts dans le
présent et ils ne savent pas ils pensent
que les choses ne s'amélioreront pas
sauf si les avenirs eux mêmes et moi
j'aimerais bien y participer aussi à ce
changement même si j'ai maintenant 67
ans
je suis à la retraite mais je me
considère comme un vieil hippie prêt à
être radicaliser à tout moment et
j'espère que ce processus de lutte va
continuer
je vais me faire l'avocat du diable
est ce que vous connaissez le volume des
produits dérivés sur les marchés
financiers est ce que vous connaissez
l'interconnexion des produits dérivés ou
des produits financiers avec les fonds
de retraite est ce que vous connaissez
l'intrication du système financier dans
notre propre vie de tous les jours
je connais le contexte australien plutôt
bien j'ai vu ses problèmes
avec les tentatives de limiter les
retraites en france
pour accroître l'âge à partir duquel les
gens peuvent partir à la retraite j'ai
vu les réactions de colère sociale
et je peux comprendre
les gens qui
ont ce genre de réaction donc mais comme
j'ai dit ces problèmes
sont
moins importantes que le réchauffement
climatique ce sont des problèmes qui
vont réduire à rien les fonds de
retraite et l'économie de pays donc en
ce qui me concerne la proportionnalité
de l'effort est nécessaire il faut
mettre les meilleurs efforts dans les
choses qui sont les plus importantes je
peux comprendre pourquoi certaines
personnes s'arrêtent au niveau des fonds
de pension et combien d'argent ils
auront à l'avenir mais je pense qu'il
est possible pour que les gens voient
plus loin et plus haut
voir que les fonds de pension n'auront
aucun sens dans un monde où il n'y aura
plus de système climatique viable
ou un système environnemental avec des
extinctions de masse des espèces
on arrive au point où les feux de
brousse australien sont extraordinaires
les camps vos maisons brûlées bien vos
priorités changent
comment comment vous percevez l'attitude
du pouvoir politique l'attitude du
pouvoir industriels face aux défis aux
menaces que représente le changement du
biotope à ce que vous considérez qu'ils
sont à la barre du bateau pour gérer peu
dans ma long ce qui à jerry s qui font
une politique symptomatique à ce qu'ils
ont un prisme de lecture à long terme où
est ce qu'ils sont devenus totalement
mégalomane
investi d'une mission divine pour
continuer ce système qui les a toujours
engraisser
je dois être d'accord avec votre
remarque conclusive
j'appelle ça le corps rampal l'isthme
corrompre donc c'est plus que
coran pour ça peut être simplement une
égratignure
l'égratignure sur votre disque vinyle au
quand tu es trop de poussière sur votre
cd le corrompt pas l'isthme ça signifie
que vous détruisez systématiquement les
fondations de la vie donc le système
politique économique nous avons créé et
maintenant dans un processus
d'autodestruction
et je ne peux parler que du système
politique australien parce que je vis en
australie non pas parce que je suis un
un quelqu'un qui fait de la science
politique mon observation c'est qu'on a
un cas classique d'une classe politique
qui est corrompue au point où il ne
gouverne pas ils sont gouvernés les
forces qui les gouvernent
les entreprises
multinationales mais
une grande partie sont des entreprises
nationales l'australienne avec beaucoup
d'investissement dans
les carburants fossiles
et donc on a un système similaire à
celui des etats unis ou une corruption
de grande échelle a lieu par des dons
aux partis politiques avec des petits
sacs pleins des valises pleines d'argent
et le résultat c'est qu'on a un système
de gouvernance qui est dans le déni de
la science et des réalités scientifiques
auxquels on doit faire face
mais c'est tellement intéressé à soi
tellement égoïste
dans cette
direction c'est qu'il faut beaucoup de
mauvaise foi pour arriver devant le
peuple et dire que on est inquiet du
futur de ses enfants et de ses
petits-enfants moi je dis que c'est un
gouvernement
d'effondrement s'est passablement
d'effondrement de la démocratie mais
je vois le corrompt pas l'isthme comme
une nouvelle force qui détruit des
fondements de la vie
pour les autres êtres humains et toutes
les autres formes de vie avec laquelle
nous partageons ce globe
comment vous anticipez le le futur de la
classe politique est-ce que vous pensez
que la classe politique va se tendre va
se durcir va se raidir face au peuple
irait dire face aux nouveaux défis en
continuant à prolonger ce schéma
intellectuelle ou est-ce que vous pensez
que la population va réussir à prendre
conscience et ensuite à faire prendre
conscience des choses ou à la caste
politique
le public devient conscient
l'exemple que je vous ai donné un
instant sur les feux de brousse en
australie c'est un mécanisme au soudain
il ya eu un changement dans le régime
disons que c'est pas tellement important
jusqu'au moment où c'est devenu la chose
la plus importante dans la vie des gens
et il est estimé que deux tiers du
public australien sont affectées
directement ou indirectement par les
feux
et vraiment c'est un coup terrible à
l'économie
sans mentionner des choses comme les
pertes de vies
mais perte de bien des gens
l'estimation ca milliards au plus
d'animaux d'oiseaux d'espèces
les voilà les kangourous le résultat
renvoie le public
faire pression sur les personnels
politique telle qu'on ne l'a pas vue
depuis une décennie
en lutte depuis plus longtemps qu'une
décennie mais bon le public
il ya une toute petite minorité
d'australiens qui tentait de changer le
climat politique
avec toute la science tout ce lot bintou
ce travail
les activistes
n'ont réussi à rien finalement mais les
feux de brousse eux ont changé tout en
un instant c'est comme un instant tel
que celui de la chute du mur de berlin
et nous les scientifiques nous tentons
de changer de tenter de comprendre ce
changement de régime
et voilà il n'y a plus de contrôle sur
ce qui se passe
je pense que ce n'est pas une réaction à
court terme je pense que maintenant
c'est quelque chose qui est
enchâssé dans l'esprit du public notre
premier ministre est un fidèle de
l'église pentecôtiste
je ne pense pas qu'il soit mal à l'aise
avec l'idée que le monde pourrait
prendre fin demain et que lui et ses
enfants disparaîtront avec lui il y
croit
et
que ce les vrais croyants seront sauvées
et que ceux qui pensent mal et bien
brûleront si ce n'est en enfer du moins
dans les forêts d'eucalyptus de
l'australie
le résultat ce genre de dirigeant n'a
pas sa place pour l'avenir de
l'australie
et
tout ce qui fait c'est du marketing
il répète la même chose au sujet de la
grandeur de la croissance économique et
de son budget
c'est la répétition de ces mantras c'est
pas simplement ennuyeux pour les
australiens c'est vraiment agressif
parce que
on et se mesure avec des problèmes de
vie et de mort
je pense que cette idée du régime
changement de régime
il ya une nouvelle dimension qui est
arrivé dans l'esprit des gens ça à voir
avec le changement climatique mais aussi
avec tout l'environnement c'est l'idée
que nous ne pouvons plus continuer à
être
les plus grands exportateurs de pétrole
du monde
c'est la fin de l'idée que
l'australie peut exister comme une
société de services it août importés de
chine les feux de brousse
et le virus récents
ont fait clairement apparaître que un
monde globalisé est un monde dangereux
et
il suffit qu'une chose aille de travers
et tout s'écroule
ils ne s'étaient plus résiliente aurait
plus de diversité
se reposeraient - sur des flux tendu et
ce rêve et n'aurait pas besoin d'une
économie de flux tendus effectivement
c'est une réponse longue à votre
question mais il n'est pas trop tard
et la science nous dit que si nous
agissons
avec de la force de l'intelligence de la
rapidité maintenant et que nous le
faisons pendant une dizaine d'années
sans arrêter nous pouvons nous mettre
sur un chemin qui nous permettra
d'éviter
l'effondrement climatique et
pour moi c'est une alerte clair
des scientifiques du monde que si nous
ne le faisons pas nous serons dans des
graves problèmes
est-ce que vous avez vu le film
idiocracy
vous conseille pour vous le résumer
succinctement et trivialement
un monde où les gens ne sont pas très
futés pas très intelligent dirigé par
une caste politique tout aussi
stupide et
et stupide
est-ce que vous pensez que
de 21e siècle
la masse de gens prient dans leurs
problèmes pris dans une distance par
rapport au biotope pris par
la vitesse du monde
est ce que cette masse de votants ne va
pas se mettre à voter pour le plus
populiste pour celui qui dira je suis le
président du pouvoir d'achat je suis le
président qui va vous permettre de vous
chauffez attentes degrés votez pour moi
ça ira mieux est ce que vous pensez pas
que cette masse facilement
instrumentalisable est trop importante
pour pouvoir renverser les choses cette
masse qui est
hypnotisé
oui j'accepte le fait que ça se produit
c'est un problème mondial massifs
auxquels il faut faire face le but
d'écrire ce livre pour moi ça a été de
subvertir ce processus à ma manière de
l'attaqué à travers les émotions
ce que la science n'arrive pas à faire
on n'arrive pas à faire de changement
significatif la classe politique et les
bureaucrates
sont tellement investi dans le passé
pour que il face à devenir un changement
donc je suis engagé dans ce qu'on peut
appeler une pensée révolutionnaire
c'est la troisième guerre mondiale c'est
la guerre des émotions ça semble
tellement binaire mais je suis prêt à
pénétrer dans une tragédie grecque mais
les forces du mal et de la destruction
font face aux forces du bien de la
création et on est vraiment à ce point
de rupture est donc comme je le donne
dans l'exemple de l'australie on est
passé d'un état où on était des gens qui
marchaient en dormant à une marche dans
l'éveil
donc soit on est séduit et hypnotisé par
les spin doctors
ou alors pour ces gens là les les feux
ne faut pas de différence on apprend
même pas de ces désastres écologiques et
environnementaux on utilise le mot sans
précédent et la science nous dit que
rien de tel ne s'est produit
précédemment dans l'histoire de
l'australie
c'est sans précédent et si ça ne peut
pas faire advenir le changement eh bien
je serais tout à fait en ligne avec vous
quelques bonnes bouteilles de vin
sur un rocking-chair
c'est tout ce qu'on pourrait faire mais
moi je fais tout ce que je peux pour
soulager la douleur parce que c'est tout
ce qui aura sens
que mac os qui le marxiste polonais a
dit un jour qu'il croyait dans la loi de
léren de la loi d'airain du progrès et
les scientifiques de 10 ce que
l'âge de la réponse arrive
la seule chose que l'on peut faire pour
aider le progrès c'est de
s'asseoir devant les
les voitures et les wagons et les
empêcher d'avancer
je crois que l'avenir ne se déroulera
que d'une seule manière c'est pas le
progrès
moi
rien est inévitable pour moi nous sommes
capables de générer
une dynamique de créativité pour pouvoir
faire face à ces problèmes est
tombé dans une paralysie perpétuelle
nantes cité une angoisse un désespoir
c'est la garantie que ce genre de
d'avenir se produira
eh bien c'est ce que je dis de l'éco
paralysie
le fait de tomber dans une forme de
de
débilité
où je ne serai plus capable de faire
quoi que ce soit pour changer cette
situation
teny
je suis pas très certain
par allah is by the stuff de donna miss
tétanie
à cotonou à kouamé pardon j'ai une autre
question comment on fait pour mon pour
mettre le monde en psychothérapie parce
que quand je vous écoute j'ai
l'impression qu'on est dans une société
profondément malade avec des gens
parfaitement adapté à cette société
profondément malade la question c'est
comment on fait pour mettre ce monde
sous psychothérapie ou lui lui montrer
qu'il est profondément malade on
s'occupe
physiquement des politiciens on organise
des manifs de hippies on fume des
pétards on a des fleurs dans les cheveux
on fait quoi où on tombe dans le
radicalisme
l'activisme radicales comme extinction
rébellion est-ce que vous soutenez
extinction rébellion
extinction rébellion est une des
réactions
je suis surpris et soulagé que mon
travail
parle plus qu'aux
politiciens et
aux universitaires il y a des rockers la
vie métal et d'autres qui ont adopté
mais point de vue et des artistes des
musiciens d'autres types de gens
créatifs des réalisateurs de cinéma
et même d'autres
conceptualise ce problème comme faisant
partie des émotions c'est pas un
problème biomédicale qui exige une
thérapie ou des médicaments ça exige une
confrontation avec nous-mêmes
et une situation inconfortable on se met
à analyser le rôle que l'humanité joue
dans sa propre destruction
et s'est exprimée à travers le modèle
actuel de
l'économie et de l'industrie de la
production et de la consommation que
nous avons
je vois cette solution comme horvat il
ya beaucoup de façons de se réveiller et
un watson appelle cela la bio philly si
la bio fils i7 moyens on peut le pousser
aussi dans la direction opposée on peut
devenir des nécrophile
apprécié la
destruction autour de nous en tirer du
plaisir mais finalement en tant
qu'espèce sociale qui a besoin
de beaucoup de temps pour que les jeunes
puissent arriver à maturité
notre capacité de voir l'opposé de
l'écocide de la nécrophilie
[Musique]
l'écho nécrophilie si on veut lui donner
un nom et donc je dirais que
plus on va du côté du négatif du côté de
la destruction
de plus en plus on se rapproche des gens
qui se rendent comptent y opposer une
tendance opposée qui nous permettent de
réussir en tant qu'espèce avec d'autres
espèces sur terre et j'écris sur le côté
opposé
du les émotions négatives qui nous
immergent actuellement elles ne sont
négatives que parce que nous avons
compris
et dans notre inconscient
il y à ses sentiments opposés
on ne peut pas voir ses sentiments
négatifs des vraiment sans avoir un
sentiment d'un lieu désirable pour que
les émotions positives puisse apparaître
pour le comprendre et l'apprécier j'ai
créé ce symbio scène qui est l'opposé de
l'entrepôt scène je vois l'entrepôt
scène comme
un compte rendu de l'état où nous sommes
actuellement nous sommes une espèce
dominante sur la planète où on est en
train de diriger tous les processus qui
se produisent actuellement sur terre
mais dans le même temps
comme les tribus de l'anthropocène nous
devenons des échecs patents en tant
qu'espèce et le lien doit être fait de
façon logique mais doit être fait aussi
d'autres façons
à travers les arts créatifs
quand je les mentionnaient précédemment
on peut commencer par
donner d expression au négatif par le
heavy métal ou le punk rock
par la part d'autres formes de
créativité humaine c'est pas simplement
démarche intellectuelle pour que la
confrontation
avec eux ont préféré ne pas voir se
produise
qu'on le veuille ou pas
ces changements ces défis à la
conscience et mon rôle en fait est de
fournir un langage qui aide les gens à
changer les normes à renverser les
normes à renverser ce qui est
conventionnel ce qui est le passé parce
qu'être coincé dans le passé ou utiliser
le langage du passé fait partie du
problème
je comprends bien que les intellectuels
doivent fournir
la mallette à outils de compréhension du
langage mais quand en face on a une
classe politique une classe de cabinet
de communication qui prennent le
contrôle de la dialectique
et que on se rencontre que
l'appauvrissement culturel
l'appauvrissement de la maîtrise de la
langue que ce soit la langue anglaise
que la langue française est ce que
c'est je vais je vais être encore dur
est ce que c'est pas du wishful thinking
de hippies et qui est que vous êtes dans
votre propre bulle et vous vous rendez
pas compte que il ya une masse informe
de gens qui ont la tête dans le guidon
dans leur problème est que l'inertie de
cette masse informe nous emmène vers le
milan
d'accord jusqu'à un certain point
dans langage dans lequel moi j'évolue en
parle déco paralysie une forme d'inertie
on est coincé dans un système enfermé
dans un système que l'on ne pense pas
pouvoir changer à notre niveau changer
les ampoules d'éclairage c'est pas
suffisant c'est aussi
[Musique]
psychologiques psychiatriques
nos problèmes affectent aussi notre
capacité
à voir clairement
et à faire cette transition
qui nous amènerait à une meilleure
qualité de vie pour nous mêmes donc suis
tout à fait conscient de ces problèmes
donc il faut que je revienne à un point
où
pourquoi faudrait-il changer
un point c'est parce que comme je le
prétends
les les négatifs
à tirin positif plus bavard négatif on
se rende compte que on a quitté notre
vide espèce humaine vers une vie qui ne
l'est plus
le plus sont ni notre nos positions nos
émotions positives + et les acquiert de
la valeur on prend pour acquis
que on n'avait pas besoin de nommer
certaines choses parce que ce n'était
pas pertinent n'avait même pas y penser
il était donné maintenant il ya des gens
qui réfléchissent
faire par exemple quels sont les
derniers endroits du monde
qui sont intacts le tourisme devient la
cause du désastre à venir d'être
écologique à venir
je comprends parfaitement comment nous
sommes enfermés dans ce système mais la
terre elle-même nous dit que
nous sommes en train de transgresser
d'une façon qui est autour destructrice
je ne souhaite pas
personnaliser la terre je ne veux pas
parler de gaia en tant que la terre
devient une personne qui est son propre
sa propre agence être animiste je suis
trop matérialiste trop réaliste pour
aller aussi loin
mais quand votre pays commence à brûler
concrètement c'est plus le moment de
réfléchir est-ce qu'on peut changer ou
pas ce que c'est votre maison est en feu
c'est un tel impact tellement grave
si vous êtes inuit et que vous vivez
dans l'arctique vous voyez que la glace
disparaît
si vous vivez en floride votre garage se
remplit d'eau il ya un poulpe qui y vit
c'est ce qui se produit dans d'autres
parties du monde
les preuves sont devant vous comme on
dire d'australie c'est plus de la
théorie
vous êtes assez heureux en france parce
que ce qui vous arrive c'est que
différents vignobles de croise pas aussi
bien où il faut que vous apportiez des
ceps de pays plus chaud pour les
replanter ici mais c'est pas une
tragédie de proportions mondiales mais
c'est le début d'un processus où vous
voyez des changements lentement
qui se produisent ce soir du lancement
donc les gens l'ignorent c'est comme un
empoisonnement lent quand le changement
est rapide et dramatique et fait peur
alors là vraiment là là ça fait peur aux
gens ça les fait peur jusqu'aux os c'est
un poison rapide et ça génère des
réactions extrêmement différentes
et pour en revenir au cas d'étude de
l'australie dans le déni
vraiment
des gens qui dormaient debout rien était
important à la place
autre que la bière le football
le barbecue n'a beaucoup de ces bonnes
choses en australie mais récemment j'ai
lu que parce qu'il faisait tellement
chaud et que la sécheresse est tellement
dure et que les feux étaient tellement
importants on ne peut plus avoir de
barbecue donc il n'ya plus des barbecues
australien c'est annulé parce qu'il est
interdit de faire du feu dans la
nouvelle galles du sud
c'est vraiment un réveil matin très dur
ça veut dire que les activités
quotidiennes doivent être changées c'est
comme le coronavirus qui arrive chez
vous et qui vous ferment votre plaisir
du dimanche vous ne pouvez plus partager
cette expérience
parce que le risque de mettre le feu la
maison de votre voisin ou aux
broussailles autour de vous est trop
grand donc soudain c'est l'imposition
d'une réalité que la plupart d'autres
vous ne souhaitez pas voir ou savoir
on voudrait éviter les australiens ont
été excellents dans ce domaine aussi bon
que les français je pense
on est dans la dic
et en haut de la ligue pour ignorer les
choses mais quand ça vaut frappe très
fort on ne peut plus continuer à
l'ignorer
mais
ça va vous affectez ça va affecter votre
mental la façon dont vous vous relier à
tout le reste
ce changement sera avec deux râteaux
vous savez en france quand on prend
conscience des choses ou une technique
qui est ancestrale ans on coupe des
têtes
est ce que vous pensez qu'on va revenir
un écoute est ce qu'on va en arriver à
un égout terrorisme
je suis pacifiste hippie des années 60
et 70
je suis en faveur
d'une approche à la gandhi pour le
changement mais j'accepte aussi le fait
que les êtres humains sont de façon
inhérente violente
j'appelle la terra fort l'été raft aura
ce sont les destructeurs de la terre ce
sont des sentiments qui vivent chez nous
ça fait partie de notre mental j'essaie
de m'en occuper en disant que le il faut
laisser sortir nos émotions lettera
naissant les terrasses fera ce sont ceux
qui détruisent les terrains naissance
sur ce qu'ils créent
il doit y avoir il y aura une sorte un
conflit est la meilleure façon de s'en
occuper c'est regarder
comment
les conflits entre les cygnes noirs se
résolvent en ciblant ainsi noir ils sont
dans l'image l'un de l'autre ils se
battent contre leur image
c'est pas quelque chose qui semble se
faire c'est une image synchronisée l'un
de l'autre
et soudain ça s'arrête et l'un des
signes 120 s'enfuit c'est une forme
d'intimidation
d'une guerre par intimidation
je me rends compte que j'appelle cela
dans le livre
le besoin de muscles faire on a besoin
de gens forts qu'ils ne soient pas
intimider par des fascistes
sinon
il faut pas être
apeuré par la nouvelle droite qui
utilisent
ce genre d'activités pour faire advenir
leur changement mais prétendre que ce
genre de gens n'existent pas s'être
vraiment naïf il faut confronter ce qui
se faire face à ce qui se passe avec nos
forces
proportionnelle à l'opposition à
laquelle on va faire face je suis
conscient aussi
du voulait que j'arrête pour l'instant
le 2e de ce que on a juste une lampe qui
a qui s'étend mais le roi
est bien que la lumière soit donc ça
tombe bien je vais pouvoir vous coupez
est ce que vous connaissez la
psychologie des foules de gustave le
bout est-ce que vous avez étudié la
psychologie des foules
et excuse
pas par le bon mais j'ai étudié quelques
aspects de la physiologie la psychologie
des foules c'est une littérature qui
doit être aussi qui doit exister en
anglais
vous savez ce que dit gustave lebon sur
la psychologie des foules
on vous le conseille chaleureusement je
vais vous poser une autre question est
ce que vous savez ce que ça veut dire
homo homini loup pouces est
l'homme est un loup pour l'homme
est-ce que ça suggère que les êtres
humains sont comme des loups
qui se soutiendrait ou ne soutiendrait
pas je ne suis pas certain du sens de
cette phrase lamy social des loups est
très intéressante
est ce que vous connaissez les black
blocs
non
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu que sur
certaines manifestations de temps en
temps il y avait des gens plus déterminé
pour aller au contact avec les forces de
l'ordre
russes a gelé vue
france on les appelle les black blocks
je pense qu en australie on doit aussi
les appuis black blocks qu'est ce que
vous pensez de sein est ce que si je
pense pas qu'on les appelle commencé en
australie ils sont là mais sont pas
appelés comme ça
ok on espère qu'ils aient la même fibre
oui absolument dix ans la même fibre
est-ce que vous cautionnez ça est ce que
vous trouvez ça normal que y ait des
gens qui décident de prendre d'autres
voix pour se faire entendre
je pense que c'est bon d'intimider les
autres de la façon dont le temps de nous
intimider mais si ça passe dans la
violence
qui nécessitent des armes des armes à
feu alors à ce moment là ça fait partie
du même problème que ce que nous
essayons de résoudre
ça sera
l'annulation de l'amm des humains une
violence contre d'autres
violences je ne dis pas ça parce que je
suis pacifiste simplement mais parce que
la seule façon dont on va arriver un
véritable changement c'est comme je le
dis
j'ai vu
à quel point des situations violentes
peuvent être résolus dans les sociétés
traditionnelles
d'êtres humains je peux le voir avec les
cygnes noirs ça veut dire qu'on peut
l'essayer
des gens forts des hommes et des femmes
fort
avec un autre ordre du jour
vous avez ils vont dans les gymnases et
se font des muscles mais ça ne produit
pas beaucoup d'électricité tout ça donc
il ya d'autres façons d'agir
j'ai toujours été conscient du fait que
la mort
de l'écologie
assassiné par ceux qui veulent arrêter
leur activité
et j'entretiens l'idée dans le livre que
là où les écolos sont tués
parce qu'ils souhaitent continuer à tuer
des rhinocéros pour leurs cornes par
exemple
c'est là où il faut prendre des armes
effectivement contre ces gens là les
éliminer mais où est la ligne entre
l'intimidation et lutter contre la
violence c'est très difficile à dire
mais là où les gens sont assassinés je
ne pense pas qu'il y ait lieu de
mettre simplement un peu des muscles
verts et de les intimider non je suis
réaliste sur l'étendue de la violence
qui est dirigé contre ceux qui sont ra
naissant
au son qui sont créateurs de vie je ne
prétends pas dans le livre que c'est une
solution facile à trouver mais
l'alternative est quelque chose soit
herman s'est pas d'avenir
quel regard vous portez sur les
institutions internationales quand on
voit l'échec des accords de paris
l'échec de kyoto ou l'échec de la coop
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse sans la
caste politique
arrêter d'attendre cette sait comment
nom venant de ou est-ce que c'est à
l'échelle locale qu'il faut s'organiser
à tous les niveaux
dans tous les lieux y a pas un niveau
qui va exclusivement des autres changer
la situation
mais vous avez raison
dans le leadership politique actuelle
il n'y a personne qui soit dans une
situation de gouverner de telle sorte
que ce changement advienne en australie
nos politiciens sont gouvernés ils ne
sont pas ceux qui gouvernent non donc
vous savez ces gens là donnent des
grandes des fonds énormes aux partis
politiques
et
d'autres organisations qui assure ce
cercle d'influencé entre les politiciens
les industries les lobbystes
ils sont tous interchangeables
c'est pas des systèmes différents
c'est un processus systématique
qui ferme le cercle du pouvoir
de telle sorte que la démocratie dans sa
forme la plus pure soit exclu peu
important que les gens votent
aujourd'hui à plus de différence entre
les principaux partis politiques
je suggère effectivement que la
démocratie
est anthropocentrique par définition
s'occupe de problèmes
pertinent pour les êtres humains mais
nous avons des sujets à régler avec le
climat à éviter l'extinction des espèces
la démocratie doit être élargi au delà
du demos et moi je suis en faveur de la
somme bio cratie c'est à dire une forme
de gouvernance pour tous les êtres
vivants et pas simplement les humains
mais bon
c'est une tentative nouvelle
je ne pense pas que la symbiose cratie
préval demain mais si des gens
commencent à
s'interroger sur la validité du demos
pourquoi est ce que nous acceptons cette
forme de gouvernance que nous avons
actuellement
un gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple comme la seule chose qui
soit importante sur terre
c'est plein du bri
cette arrogance et de la dominance et du
l'autoritarisme on avait par le passé je
souhaite que les gens réfléchissent
différemment et c'est le but de mes
nouveaux mots de mon nouveau langage
je pense que nous sommes tous et moi
j'étais professeur de durabilité et les
gens me disent mais qu'est-ce qui va pas
avec le durabilité c'est un beau concept
whissell les thèmes maintenant qui est
ce qu'on a pris possession
eh bien c'est la classe industrielle qui
en a pris possession pour justifier de
sa propre licence tout devient durable
ce com résilience
c'était
des gentils universitaire à stockholm
qui avait mis cela en avant c'est très
une bonne direction vers laquelle à
libre les êtres humains
je ne dirais pas qu'il faut pas être
résilient mais trump donald trump et
utilise le mot résilience aujourd'hui
pour éviter de s'occuper des causes du
changement climatique le gouvernement
australien utilise le mot résilience
parce que c'est un chouette mots parce
que c'est bien utilisé
forment-ils transition
un autre mot et transition transition
vers quoi ça aucun sens donc on est
plein de ces choses là
quand j'enseignais j'ai essayé que mes
étudiants voient la différence entre la
véritable résilience et la résilience
pervertit les résidents les résidences
pervertissent et la résilience des
choses qui devraient être éliminés comme
les mauvaises odeurs elle reste là on
peut pas s'en débarrasser et donc la
résilience devient quelque chose de
négatif une condition négative lorsque
le show sont indésirables et deviennent
apparemment impossible à éliminer
je commence à voir le rôle de la langue
comme joue un rôle extrêmement important
dans l'animation du système actuel et si
vous êtes intéressés par le potentiel et
la possibilité du changement non
seulement il faut l'attaquer par la
science et par l'idéologie politique qui
est une autre possibilité
est explorée par d'autres gens que moi
beaucoup plus en détail mais si on
utilise le langage pour
exposer faire exploser ses échecs pour
avoir
de nouvelles émotions
c'est comme dans le film le magicien
d'oz en tire le rideau et puis le grand
le grand sorcier deux roses c'est un
pauvre petit bonhomme pour petit
magicien qui prétend être puissant mais
ya rien en fait
si je vous dis on ne peut pas ressentir
ce que l'on peut ne ce que l'on ne peut
pas verbalisés
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de vérité
là-dedans
des sentiments
qui sont importants
qu'on n'a pas réussi à articuler
ce commentaire devrait être menée plus
loin
j'écris au sujet de l'extinction des
émotions
nous vivons dans une culture
qui a enlevé nos capacités d'avoir des
engagements émotionnel avec ce qui est
important c'est une forme de diniz à
sion
il y à un terme pour cela on réduit le
monde
a une sorte de poupée
il ne dort et insipide si on peut tendre
le langage
vers des choses mauvaises on peut le
dire et j'ai aussi vers des choses bode
pour stimuler les bons les bonnes
émotions
voilà ce qui est fait par les gens qui
sont créatifs
lettera naissant c'est ainsi que l'on
travaillera un effet plus important
moi je suis en mission si vous voulez
pour créer la terminologie le cadre
conceptuel les mots nécessaires pour
décrire le nouveau monde vers lequel
nous souhaitons aller
hop toupie pour tout et corners sheepers
new world
bien entendu et de créer les créent eux
mêmes
je vois mon rôle comme subversif
dire pourquoi faut-il accepter le
langage des spin doctors et des
politicards non seulement c'est ennuyeux
mais il faut on n'est pas obligé
d'écouter un robot
ils ont des programmes pour quelle que
soit la question qu'on leur pose les
auront toujours la même réponse nous
sommes à une époque aujourd'hui où les
gens en sont fatigués
et on peut voir que cette une forme de
faussetés qui est évidente aujourd'hui
les gens ne font même plus semblant de
dire la vérité
je vous ouvre une parenthèse
avant que le directement soit discuté un
petit peu de vent de voyage en allemagne
et vous m'avez dit que c'était beaucoup
plus facile de rentrer en france
on vous a pas posé de questions mais
quand vous êtes rentré en allemagne là
vous êtes fait attraper par la loisne
ils vous ont posé beaucoup de questions
pourquoi votre avis via aux élections
justes cube de la couette
si j'allais aux états unis je pense
qu'il y aurait beaucoup plus de
questions qui seront posées
mettront peut-être un petit toucher
rectal au passage
je dois dire que ça m'est arrivé par le
passé j'étais au canada
au moment de l'attaqué contre les tours
jumelles les twin towers j'ai pris un
rendez vous pour voir un universitaire
que je respecte beaucoup le brocciu un
écho anarchiste qui vivaient dans le
vermont et pour passer du canada aux
états unis ça impliquait
comment dirais-je un profilage racial
moi je suis mon humble en
gens ne croyaient pas que j'étais lié à
l'université et j'ai dû passer par tout
le processus et les convaincre que
j'étais de bonne foi
comme ma femme puis mes enfants ont
plaisanté
heureusement que j'avais une bonne
famille blanche sans ça ils meurent est
tenu et retenu pendant très très
longtemps
ce processus d'être profiler m'est
arrivé à plusieurs reprises je comprend
ce qui se passe
j'ai été arrêté parce que j'étais un
terroriste moluques quoi aux pays-bas
dans les années 70 donc j'ai vraiment
une longue histoire
de profilage
iran dès ma vie inconfortable est-ce que
vous avez été arrêté en allemagne pour
vous poser des questions parce que
l'allemagne produit du chardon exploite
du charbon est ce qu'ils ont fait le
parallèle entre les couilles pis
terroriste australien qui vient
peut-être armes et les consciences et
les esprits en allemagne est-ce que
c'était démarche dissuasive d'autres
sensations
non j'aurais bien aimé être aussi
célèbre que cela non c'est pas le cas
les allemands sont
seul toit pas deux c'est ça
juste un doigt oui
j'ai pensé que ma venue
était pacifique par rapport à mes
tentatives de rentrer dans les états
unis et même pour rentrer en australie
vous devez passer par des processus
bureaucratique plus que dans tout autre
pays donc je ne peux pas
blâmer les allemands pour demander
m'avoir demandé pourquoi j'allais en
allemagne même si vous entrez dans un
pays de l'union européenne
c'est comme si vous entrez dans tous les
pays de l'union européenne je ne connais
pas la bureaucratie
2 millions européenne pas du tout tout
ce que je sais c'est que
les britanniques ont voulu en sortir ils
ont réussi donc ça sera difficile pour
eux de rentrer en europe ils devront
passer par les mêmes questionnements
pourquoi voulez-vous venir que faites
vous ou allez vous résidez
c'est vraiment
la fin de cette possibilité de voyage l
international tel qu'on l'a connu
précédemment c'est une des conséquences
de la destruction des tours jumelles et
du terrorisme a eu un impact sur le
monde mais c'est un problème différent
vous ouvre une parenthèse je vous coupe
imaginez qu'un groupe terroriste
avait brûlé autant d'hectares de forêts
en australie avait tué autant de koala
et kangourou avait mis un bordel
tellement monstrueux
est ce que on serait déjà en guerre
contre eux on aurait déployé les avions
l'aorte avion les systèmes de
renseignement toussa toussa
savons fait pas bizarre
que
y ait cette détresse environnementale et
que le mouvement va t'en guerre contre
cette menace
soit vraiment rachitique par rapport à
la réponse hypothétique qu'ils auraient
déployé contre un mouvement terroriste
c'est un peu tangentielle à mai le
gouvernement australien a tenté de faire
porter le chapeau au mouvement
extrémiste
[Musique]
écologique australien parce que les
mouvements écologiques australien
avait mis la pression sur
les personnes qui s'occupent des forêts
l'administration des forêts en australie
ce sont les écologistes qui ont
en fait interdit les brûlis est donc
cette guerre idéologique a eu lieu
quelques heures
dès que les feux en affecter les
l'australie c'était une bagarre et de
logique une guérite aux logiques qui n'a
pas cessé elle continue
ça ne me surprend pas que la classe
dominante dirigeante le fasse parce que
évidemment ça évite que la faute leur
soit attribué
on fait glisser les réalités des
problèmes et ça permet aux dirigeants de
partir en vacances pendant les feux
élire jean quitter le pays
un pays en feu donc il ya une colère
en même temps qu'il y à une nouvelle
conscience
qui se génère quand le public
perd la foi dans la classe politique
perd confiance dans la voie politique
pas simplement pour qu'ils aient une
position descente mais sur les positions
qui sont les leurs
ils ont lutté
pour maintenir
démocratie parlementaire
s ce que vous avez essayé de les
comprendre avec un autre prisme de
lecture les comprendre la classe
politique est ce que vous avez essayé de
comprendre que pour eux à court terme la
menace économique est beaucoup plus
dévastatrice et délétère que la menace
écologique c'est-à-dire qu'ils font une
politique symptomatique parce que le
danger d'un déraillement d'une
défaillance du système économique si on
dit voilà maintenant vous allez arrêter
d'épuiser le biotope parce que c'est
plus possible les les systèmes
financiers vont faire la tête et donc la
menace de déstabilisation du système
économique pour eux et peut-être mille
fois plus importante que
1 milliard de kangourou cramer
vous avez raison dans ce diagnostic
c'est exactement ce qui se passe
on pourrait l'appeler du court termisme
ça va réussir pendant un certain temps
mais comme pour le magicien d'oz
la nature force de cette réponse sera
démontrée et je dirais que
le système économique
sous tend
ce qui se faisait déjà dans les années
70 avec ce concept d'économie stable
hier yens nouveau et c'est pas quelque
chose pour lequel je prends
crédit mais c'est vous savez c'est le
principe de la thermodynamique
on peut pas avoir un système de
développement continu et quand on pousse
cette idée trop loin en disant oui on
peut faire ce qu'on veut on peut
continuer
ainsi on va on va rentrer dans le mur et
on a on est déjà rentrer dans le mur en
australie est-ce qu'on est rentré dans
le mur il suffisamment violemment je ne
sais pas c'est de la politique qui se
produit en temps réel maintenant
j'ai j'ai quelques questions d'un ami
qui s'appelle pablo service qui me les
envoyer je vais je vais vous en pause et
2 3 la première c sommes nous prêts
émotionnellement à affronter le 21ème
siècle
pour affronter le 21e siècle
ma réponse est que nous ne sommes pas
prêts émotionnellement parce qu'on n'a
pas la langue le langage pertinents les
concepts pertinents la critique
pertinente
de
langage
qu'on a essayé par le passé pour
s'occuper de ses problèmes ne sert à
rien je ne dis pas que je suis la seule
personne qui tendent
se mesure à ses problèmes à travers un
objectif émotionnel mais je suis heureux
de voir que je suis un pionnier dans ce
domaine et je voudrais que cette
approche soit suivie par beaucoup plus
de gens pour qu'on puisse voir le rôle
des émotions
la centralité du rôle des émotions au
21ème siècle est pas quelque chose qui
devrait être ignorée aux quelque chose
de marginal parce que au 19e siècle qui
nous a dit que les émotions n'était pas
une expérience humaine valable et devait
être exclu de la prise de décision ou
exclues du royaume de
du savoir et laissé dans au domaine de
l'intuition jeudi que la bonne science
et des bonnes émotions doivent
travailler ensemble pour donner une
bonne société et je dirais que
la récupération des bonnes émotions
est absolument fondamental pour le 21e
siècle
et si on ne le fait pas
l'extinction de nos émotions
sera le début de quelque chose ils
seront incapables de résister aux forces
que vous avez mentionné
nos réactions sont
éliminés par des forces qui sont
tellement grande qu'elle anticipe toute
action que de pures ion faire et le
commercialisera et nous rendre inertes
vie yves barbreau
oui
j'aimerais connaître mieux la barbarie
je ne vais pas étudié mais je crois
savoir de quoi on parle j'ai une autre
question pour vous toujours de pablo est
ce qu'on se remet de la soul est algie
ou est-ce que ça va durer toute la vie
l'arrivée
de la star au stade j ai dû conditions
en italie peut être l'inversé
des lits des caddies
jamais enfermer dans des endroits
comme sterling
c'est tellement profit
c'est une situation de sortie
c'est comme la star i7 vous tuez lieux à
pied ou la convertir
non j'ai pas entendu parler formé au
regard de ce
qui précède
à l'homme qui s'est immolé
à
la réponse
extrême et tragique
d'un point de vue humain mais je crois
qu'il est possible
de s'occuper des causes de la sla stade
j je les mentionnaient précédemment la
restauration la réparation une des
choses que l'on peut faire pour aider
lutter contre le système qui de cause
j'étais impliqué dans des communautés ou
des groupes
qui ont mené rio tinto devant les
tribunaux
dans les tribunaux de nouvelle galles du
sud pour comprendre les les implications
et les effets du bruit de la poussière
sur l'environnement
la perte de biodiversité
las la salle j c'était un état négatif
que les gens ressentaient qui leur
étaient imposées et qui n'étaient pas
justifiable même en terre des bénéfices
économiques on en tire est que cette
mine de charbon apporterait aux gens
et le gouvernement à
changer la législation pour annuler le
résultat est là la décision de la cour
est donc nous avons perdu mais ça montre
que la lutte peut se faire à différents
niveaux
j'ai au moins il ya eu
une décision de justice ou une mine de
charbon
n'a pas été autorisé et l'inclusion de
la seule fille
qui était inclus donc cette notion
inclus dans le jugement est ce là s'agit
ne pouvait pas être imposée par une mine
de charbon
et donc l'ouverture de cette mine a été
refusé ma réponse à cette question c'est
que on peut défier les forces qui crée
la sau la salle j
on peut s'engager
dans une forme de réforme
qui soit la réforme de l'environnement
biophysique qui est endommagé une
réforme des processus politiques
économiques qui créent et c'est dommage
et dans ce processus ou est capable de
réformer et réparer vos dommages
psychologiques
las la salle joly peut être allégée et
enlever
une autre question que pensez vous de la
théorie des cinq stades de la fin de vie
de que blur rance et autres théories du
deuil est ce que ça peut aider à
traverser cette tempête
question extrêmement complexe
et de la réponse doit être complexe
aussi
je vois le deuil comme une réaction
à notre besoin de comprendre la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
le deuil techniquement comme je le
comprends en anglais est un sentiment
qui vient lorsque l'on perd le contact
avec quelqu'un de vivant qui meurt et
nos relations intimes doivent cesser
avec cette personne le cinquième état de
kübler-ross c'est l'acceptation si on y
arrive et je pense que c'est la
situation la plus désastreuse que l'on
peut avoir dans notre situation il ne
faut pas accepter le deuil il faut se
rebeller contre le deuil il faut
les gens parlent de différents types de
deuil ont dit et caudry par exemple
voilà on a fait avec le deuil tout ce
qu'on pouvait faire avec le deuil
comme d'autres émotions humaines
et bien que j'apprécie et que je
comprends la logique pour ce faire
je préférerais
que en face en prennent plus soin du
langage émotionnel que nous utilisons le
climat ne meurt pas même s'il est
endommagée il est toujours là nous ne
pouvons pas détruire l'environnement tel
qu on le comprend on peut le changer
d'une façon on n'aime pas mais c'est pas
quelque chose qui est présent dans notre
vie
on peut penser que l'on peut éteindre
toute vie sur la planète mais en fait et
des bactéries qui aiment vivre
près des volcans sous marins il y en a
d'autres qui l'aiment encore plus chaud
son environnement
ce sont des bactéries qui adore l'hyper
chaleur c'est une forme d'arrogance de
penser que l'on peut détruire
ou éteindre complètement les choses
qui sont partis de ce grand photographe
problème
faire le deuil il faut faire le deuil
des choses que nous avons définitivement
perdu mais même là je pense que la
culture humaine
et le concept de deuil a une pertinence
dans toutes les cultures humaines
et il ya des façons de le comprendre et
d'exprimer notre deuil parfois il faut
prendre des idées
de notre culture de la mettre dans un
autre contexte donc je suis en faveur de
cela je donne un exemple dans le livre
des inuit
de l'arctique
qui ont l'expérience un d'un changement
rapide est négatif de des glaces la
tristesse
c'était difficile pour eux de comprendre
cela leur façon de le faire c'est qu'ils
ont pris un mot de leur culture qui
était au ghana tor
qui signifie un ami qui agit de façon
bizarre on va avec un au bar avec un
copain qui boit un coup de trop qui
commencent à vous balancer des coups de
poing c'est dérangeant votre ami agi
d'une façon imprévisible
il n'avait pas de mots pour la façon
dont le climat agissait presque
semblable à analogique par exemple à la
façon dont cet ami se comportait mal
donc ils ont détruit décrit le climat
qui devenait ogada toc c'est une
question que toutes les cultures lutte
pour trouver la terminologie les mots
pour décrire ce changement profond qui a
lieu nous sommes à une étape où nous
luttons pour trouver les bons mots pour
décrire
le les tempêtes émotionnelle dans
laquelle nous sommes ma tâche mon
travail
a été de tenter d'être plus précis
plus que de mettre égaux devant ou éco
de vendeuil les cowboys n'ont jeu des
problèmes pas simplement avec
l'application du terme deuil mais aequo
et court vient de highco ce qui signifie
en grec la gestion de la maisonnée la
gouvernance de la maison et je n'aime
pas particulièrement un moquer des
implications de domination humaines et
de gouvernance qui soit appliquée à la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
actuellement où la domination humaine et
la gouvernance ont causé les problèmes
qui nous donne ici
de haïr c'est pas une insulte au peuple
indigène qui ont une relation plus
intime avec le reste de la vie qui sont
décrits dans les confins de loïc hausse
donc il ya un problème là
de l'appropriation culturelle dans un
sens on utilise des systèmes haut des
biosciences pour décrire toute leur
expérience en relations avec le reste du
monde
c'est pas très productif et l'autre oeil
cos l'économie la gestion de l'économie
ne parlons du capital naturel
le biodiversité
toutes ces choses où nous tentons de
dire
si nous sommes des bons capitalistes
nous verrons comment on peut verdir le
capitalisme loïc aux devient vert et
nous vivront heureux pour toujours c'est
une situation extrêmement dangereuse à
adopter mais bon je compense coup dit
désolé de faire des choses que les gens
ne voient pas mais on sait bien compris
j'ai une question intérieure qui est
très courte mais qui est lourde de
signification une question de louis
jacques que pense-t-il des problèmes lie
aux réfugiés climatiques
cette un problème est excessivement
compliqué
j'y pense de différentes manières l'une
d'entre elle sait
nous voyons déjà un monde
profondément
altérée par le changement global dans
le climat qui force les gens à
immigrer d'un endroit à l'autre
la montée des eaux va changer cela
dramatiquement les réfugiés climatiques
à l'avenir seront se compteront par
millions si ce n'est par milliards et ça
affectera tous les continents toutes les
îles c'est pas comme si simplement
quelqu'un allait souffrir de cela et
d'autres
les vitres est
l'idée
que l'on peut surmonter facilement ça
c'est de l'utopie
ça va créer des graves problèmes à
l'humanité j'en parle dans mon livre en
disant qu' on a besoin d'une culture
hybride urgentes qui accepte un peu du
passé et
et l'importance de la géographie
la terre n'est pas uniforme elle génère
des réactions différentes en divers
endroits
les gens d'un autre endroit viennent
ils sont forcés de quitter leurs maisons
leurs terres leur espace ils doivent
s'ajuster
aux façons de vivre de ceux qui les
accueillent
et ceux qui les accueillent sont des
chats
cette expérience d'homogénéisation du
monde
la colonisation
d'autres espèces
de tous les autres endroits donc cette
idée d'un espace pure qui doit être
protégé doit être abandonnée dans le
même temps l'idée que les migrants
du viennent simplement avec leur vision
du monde et leur relation à
l'environnement à l'agriculture et à
d'autres choses sans être influencés par
leurs hôtes
que ce soit le changement climatique ou
des raisons différentes
nous sommes dans un espace qui exige
cette réaction créative
etc ni la gauche ni la droite ce n'est
pas lié au passé c'est un avenir qui
doit être construit et bien sûr
c'est trop facile de dire qu' il faut le
faire
quels sont les aspects techniques
et j'émets un message
venez aider je me bats contre je me bats
avec ses idées très complexe on a besoin
de plus de gens qui réfléchissent à ça
j'ai une question internet que je vais
essayer de reformuler de ne pas
dénaturer est ce que vous pensez pas que
d'avoir inventé le mot solace talent j
ce n'est pas une façon de psychiatrisés
les gens qui parlent de la colle absolue
j ai don de les discréditer
c'est une critique de mon travail
disons que c'est la construction sociale
de la réalité
ou l'invention d'une nouvelle maladie
mentale
dont on pourrait s'occuper en la
médicalisant olam est dit quand
c'est loin de ma pensée lorsque j'ai
créé ce concept
mais
vous savez
j'accepte que d'autres personnes
l'interprète différemment de ce que moi
j'ai pensé comme en littérature ou en
art d'ailleurs et je dois être plus
attentifs à la façon faire plus
attention de la façon dont j'exprime des
choses parce que parfois des mauvaises
interprétations peuvent se produire
mais moi je le décrirais comme
prenant des risques en créant ce
concept de ce la stèle
et
peut-être que je ne me suis pas exprimé
suffisamment clairement en utilisant un
mot comme maladie
qui mènerait les gens à penser que je
médicalisent certains problèmes oh que
je crée un problème psychologique là où
il s'agit d'une fabrication
les concepts vous savez passe au test
non pas à l'université
de façon très rigoureuse mais aussi pas
seulement à l'université mais la façon
dont les gens réagissent tomo si c'est
accepté s'il est accepté grand demande
dans une vérité de concepts et de
contexte ça signifie que ça une capacité
à engager
les gens
j'ai même eu des gens des aborigènes
australiens qui sont venus me voir et
qui m'ont dit qu'ils approuvaient ce
concept parce que ça ne crée quelque
chose qui leur arrive et que leur propre
langue n'arrivait pas exprimé
ça revient au ghana toque à cette
histoire toutes les cultures lutte avec
cette histoire de changement global
rapide
c'est pour ça que le titre du livre ces
nouveaux mots pour un nouveau monde jeux
j'y crois nous luttons pour articuler
les choses dont on parle actuellement
parce que notre langue a été appauvrie
en ce qui concerne ces problèmes-là
appauvri parce qu'on n'a pas eu à
s'occuper par le passé ça ne fait pas
partie de notre expérience de
l'évolution comme
espèce mondialisée
j'ai une autre question de la communauté
je vais vous la pose donc en anglais
avec mon plus bel accent parce qu'ils
l'ont posée en anglais ils ont fait
l'effort de la pause en anglais
odudu waits and language coudry voorhees
defect 9,2 authority autorité riz en
arbre italie laws of physics
waterworld koudou games entre pouilles
excepté au self sommes fairy tales and
beliefs en velours coudes quand on sait
ce qu'on compte sur sa conscience
est-ce que cela porte sur
je suis pas très certain des lois de la
physique là
moi je lutte l'entropie à chaque fois
que je la rencontre
je lutte contre l'entropie conceptuel là
où nos concepts sont perdus dans
d'une homogénéité entre ennui yeuse d'un
univers un sens c'est ce qui est le
résultat final de la deuxième loi de la
thermodynamique
si je comprends bien la question
comment est-ce que je réagis
personnellement
à cette rupture
de ce qui intéresse est vital de la vie
sur terre la destruction par ceux qui
tentent de le transformer en tant que
mort de l'univers
la vie et d'une stratégie qui s'oppose
à l'entreprise justement je suis père
grand père
il faut que je pense que la vie de façon
inhérente est bonne et que la mort c'est
ennuyeux et être du côté de la vie c'est
une bonne lutte
j'utilise mes capacités de
réflexion pour construire un avenir pour
l'humanité où la vie serait beaucoup
plus importante qu'elle ne l'est
actuellement
dans cette ère dans laquelle nous sommes
dans cet entrepôt scène je l'appelle
l'obscène
incapable de valoriser la vie au delà
l'égocentrisme et les privilégiés
si je vous dis heureux les simples
d'esprit aujourd'hui j'ai compris
j'ai essayé aussi de
faire revivre notre spiritualité
avec
ce mot de guide gail jada est
je ne sais pas à quel point cette idée
réussira je crois que les marchands de
spiritualité classiques sont passés de
mode ça va je tente de laïciser ce que
je trouve extraordinaire au sujet de la
vie
et je l'appelle le guide aist parce que
les gays d'
dans les vieux langage indo-européen
c'est
la racine des mots qui disent bon bien
ensemble
c'est de là l'origine de ces termes dans
les anciennes préfixe indo européen
je suis prêt à tenter quelque chose de
nouveau parce que j'ai vu l'échec du
passé a donné quelque chose de pertinent
pour le 21e siècle et donc je ne le fais
pas parce que j'aime inventer des choses
je le fais parce que j'aime parce que je
vois qu'il manque quelque chose un vide
peut être remplies pour que nous êtres
humains puissions commencer une
conversation utile est bonne sauf que ça
signifie d'avoir une vie spirituelle
dans un monde laïc
peut-être que c'est dingue mais jeu
j'essaie de le faire combien vous gagnez
ont donc retraité
ça me coûte de l'argent
de faire ce que je fais je ne gagne rien
combien vous gagnez avec votre pension
de retraite
eh bien j'ai gelé dépensés pour acheter
ma ferme et faire croître des bégu mme
je n'ai aucun investissement personnel
dans le marché boursier ou dans un fonds
de pension
je suis un homme entretenu en quelque
sorte parce que ma femme a une retraite
j'ai décidé que je ne pouvais pas
laisser mon argent dans un système que
je tente de détruire mais heureusement
ma femme n'est pas aussi folle que moi
et donc elle prend soin de moi
on va parler de d'un australien du plus
français des australiens julian assange
est ce qu'on peut dire un mot sur julian
assange
ces mécanismes de défense que vous
utilisez la
non c'est que moi j'ai suivi
wikileaks je comprends la position
d'alger mais pas simplement
je soutient wikileaks je soutiens
la libération d'assange
lorsque il n'a commis aucun crime contre
la suède ou les suédois et
sont le traitement qui lui est infligé
est abominable c'est une injustice donc
je soutiens
ceux qui aimeraient que
quelqu'un qui a tenté
de faire connaître la vérité au public
de telle sorte que les forces de
l'autorité tentaient d'éviter
j'ai des inquiétudes
lorsque la
diffusion de l'information peut faire du
mal à d'autres
je ne pense pas que ça a été le cas avec
wikileaks et l'information qui a été
révélé
donc nos positions c'est que
c'est un australien qui est citoyen du
monde qui souffrent et dans une
injustice qui se poursuit
c'est quelque chose d'une des choses les
pires que j'ai vu dans la société
contemporaine
on arrive à la fin notre interview on a
pour habitude de poser deux dernières
questions
la première c est ce que vous avez trois
livres a conseillé à notre communauté et
la dernière c est ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations et
rapidement comment s'appelle votre livre
les émotions de la terre de nouveaux
mots pour un nouveau monde c'est un bon
livre j'aime bien que les gens le lisent
je ne dirais pas que c'est un des trois
mais c'est très difficile comme question
je lis beaucoup et je suis influencé par
un très grand nombre de gens
si je me rapproche du domaine qui
m'inspire qui me donne
des choses
étudier je lis
revote macfarlane
publié qui a publié un livre
les relation émotionnelle et mentale
au monde
quelque chose qui est souterrain
que des choses verrait comme ayant un
lien à mon propre travail
en ce qui concerne la philosophie
environnementale
je suis inspirée par
aldo leopold
et laisser réfléchir comme une montagne
5 de rakhine ça une résonance dans ma
vie depuis le moment où je les lui très
tôt et j'espère qu'il est disponible en
traduction en français
j'espère que ça a été publié
depuis l'époque où il était publié en
anglais dans les années 50 et
je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui écrit
beaucoup sur la nature moi j'écris sur
les humains et sur les réactions
humaines
mais j'ai lu un livre
de et jebha que le pèlerin
ces observations de ces oiseaux
étant amoureuse de des oiseaux ayant
passé la plus grande partie de sa vie
moi en cherchant la compagnie des
oiseaux
et il ya partagé le monde avec eux je
recommanderais la lecture du pèlerin de
bec pas simplement parce que c'est
vraiment
très belle écriture et en anglais j'ai
trouvé
ça son écriture sa capacité
d'écrire et amener le lecteur
dans un monde qui n'existe peut-être
plus
dans l'angleterre d'après guerre
je livre décrit
l'avis du faucon pèlerin à travers les
yeux d'un observateur
d'oiseaux
mais par beaucoup d'aspects
se relie directement mon travail ce
livre seront liés à mon travail
backès tombe sur un oiseau mort
de couleur jaune et ils s'inquiètent
du fait que l'oiseau a pu être
empoisonné
et il va plus loin il parle
de la puanteur de l'argent qui
envahissait la vie des oiseaux
comme salt spring de casse
qui considère le rôle des humains dans
ce qu'on appelle l'écocide ou le terreau
acide la destruction et l'assassinât de
la terre et les cris au sud quelque
chose
qui est notre incapacité à faire
attention et à observer ce qui se
produit autour de nous
ce qui reste du monde de la nature
il décrit un homme
qui traverse
un pont digue
près de la mer il est complètement pris
par sa carte routière et sa carte
routière l'empêchent de voir ce qu'il ya
autour de lui il y a des
baleines qui sont en train de migrer
et qui brille dans le soleil mais ils ne
les voient pas
et je le vois ce passage comme semblable
au monde dans lequel on vit
je suis dans un taxi pour venir ici à
cette interview cette entrevue il ya des
gens qui sont tout à côté de la tour
eiffel mais tout ce qu'ils font c'est
qu'ils regardent leur téléphone portable
alors que
fut des architectures les plus
merveilleuses au monde est à côté d'eux
il ne la regarde pas on le fait en ville
imaginez un peu
ce que
ce qu'on fait
avec les oiseaux qui existe encore dans
la nature personne ne fait plus
attention à eux c'est l'extinction des
émotions
l'extinction de l'expérience
qui inquiète plus que toute autre chose
et lire un livre sur le faucon pèlerin
ses joyaux d'écriture
reste avec moi et deviennent
globalisé et en fait la carte physique
est remplacé par google earth et le
téléphone mobile au lieu de regarder la
nature
sans médiation on essaie de la regarder
à travers un objectif
une lentille à travers une cartographie
qui n'est pas réel du tout
une cartographie artificiel c'est une
myopie un aveuglement que nous avons
relié de regarder le monde
si on ne regarde
c'est vraiment enthousiasmant et de ne
pas le voir c'est tragique et en
espérant que mon travail et en créant
des mots qui vont tenter de décrire ces
états positif on en a pas parlé dans ses
interviews mais on a parlé de lotir ya
qui est un sentiment
positif qui est un sentiment d'unicité
avec la terre
et cette expérience océaniques que les
surfeurs les freudiens et certains
mystiques
ressentent cette expérience océaniques
nécessitent que l'on fasse attention à
ce qui se produit dans le monde avoir de
l'empathie et de le rejoindre cet outil
est
d'avoir ce sentiment positif
réconfortant d'unités il n'y a pas de
lien entre l'inconnu et le connu
je veux une petite part en 13 ans entre
vous et moi
le cannabis qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'ai essayé jeune homme
mais bon ça
ça un produit quelque chose sur mon
appétit ça permet l'appréciation de la
musique de façon utopique
au delà du normal
au delà de ce qu'on peut attendre d'un
certain point de vue donc lorsque je
reviens à des tas normal
un état non augmenté de la connaissance
je suis un peu déçu du fait que la
réalité ne correspondent plus à l'utopie
mais après un certain temps je me suis
rendu compte que la réalité c'est tout
ce que j'avais et que l'utopie était une
forme d'échappatoire
et j'essaie d'éviter
dans ma vie adulte
excepté et un bon verre de vin rouge
d'obtenir trois autres dernières
questions encore 1,9 un exemple pour les
jeunes générations
je pense
se rebeller et le coeur de ce que je
pourrais suggéré
extinction rébellion et greta sont sur
le bon chemin j'ai pris part aux grèves
des écoles à nu casse la ville la plus
proche l'endroit où je vis et je vois
dans la jeunesse et en particulier
une vision du futur
au moins semblables à ceux que j'aime
moins avec le symbio scène un rejet du
présent et du passé et un désir intense
de se voir dans un avenir
qu'ils créeront eux mêmes
qui seront avec kylie seront à l'aise
même plus qu'à l'aise plus que
confortable qui les enthousiasmera je
pense que ce sont des homo sapiens
véritable qui utiliseront l'intelligence
d'une manière que les autres ont
échoué à faire nous avons brûlé fait
exploser des choses ce qui n'est pas une
avancée par rapport à l'âge de pierre
le brûlement les explosions c'est un hub
rice
la génération qui veut utiliser
l'intelligence qu'à l'être humain sont
sur un un chemin différent
tel que décrit par naomi klein et
d'autres c'est que c'est un moment de
changement ils n'ont aucune part dans le
présent il ne possède rien ils peuvent
voir que l'avenir
de routinier destructeur je n'ai aucun
conseil à leur donner ils savent très
bien où aller
si je pouvais
un moment penser que le symbio scène est
un avenir que j'aimerais avoir
avoir une vision d'un avenir désirable
il faut travailler dur pour y arriver si
vous vous rebeller sans vision d'une
alternative au présent
c'est contre-productif parce que contre
quoi vous rebellez vous
vers quoi voulez-vous aller si
simplement une transition que c'est pas
une rébellion vous devez avoir une
vision de l'avenir
sinon ce sera un rêve creux de ce qui
serait meilleur que le présent
ce que je vois comme
c'est pas un avis un conseil c'est ce
qu'il ya dans le symbio scène on ne peut
pas s'en sortir c'est un endroit où on
veut n'aimerait rester pour toujours
donc ça le potentiel de d'amener à un
processus d'innovation sans fin mais il
faut énormément de travail sans fin
il n'y a pas de chômage dans le symbio
scène c'est une vision de l'avenir qui
vaut la peine d'être adopté
vous savez un avenir dystopia un des
tracés dans un coin et de se frapper la
tête
abandonné
l'espoir
accepter le deuil non c'est
l'acceptation de ce que j'ai déjà dit
je suis en faveur de ceux qui résistent
et probablement si cette résistance a
besoin d'une aide
d'un vieux baby boomers je serais très
heureux de leur offrir
les forces qui me reste eh bien elles
seront dédiés à l'
canal bright merci
merci de m'avoir invité
et à votre programme qui est vraiment un
défi en soi
[Musique]